one thing I love about you as a female
is you help show other women that you
can be friends with your exes I love
that you had Brad Pitt on your goop Q
and A recently yeah how did that come to
be have you guys always stayed friends
Through The Years in touch we when we
first broke up we weren't friends for a
while and then we sort of found our way
back
um probably about I don't know 18 or 19
years ago something like that and then
just kind of stayed in touch over the
years and I adore him he's an amazing
person and he's a great entrepreneur and
such a creative and such a good person I
really I love him I'm a big fan and now
he's in skincare too and now he's into
skin care have you gotten a chance to
try it no but I'm gonna I'm going to
what does your husband Brad think of the
friendship with Brad because in it we're
all adults yeah we all understand like
what does he think my husband is
probably like the least judgmental
most secure man in our relationship so
he I think he he totally respects and
probably one of the things that he likes
about me is that I believe in conscious
uncoupling whether it's like you're
uncoupling with a co-worker a spouse a
boyfriend you know um that I really do
believe that if you've invested in
somebody and of course there are
exceptions but to amputate that
relationship I is um you know maybe
you're not like then fully letting the
full lesson reveal itself and the
healing happens so even though sometimes
it can be uncomfortable I think it's
nice to work through it and reconnect
with the value that that person brought
to your life well speaking of with your
husband congratulations on your
four-year wedding anniversary thank you
I know it's different for every couple
but what would you say is the secret
that makes your marriage so strong with
Brad I a couple of things I think you
know we have amazing chemistry and like
so that's that's
a great part of a foundation you know
um
I just my body feels really good when
he's around so that's just luck and then
I think we've learned a lot from our
first marriages and
you know I think we have a great almost
reverence for
commitment and you know building
continuing to nourish a marriage and we
we are very um I think we've become
really good communicators and so that's
a very important part I wanted to ask
you as a daughter who is very close with
my mother when I saw you said dropping
off your daughter at College it was more
profound than birth I mean how emotional
was that experience because it is it's
the worst
oh God I'm
I'm still trying to get used to her not
being in the house every day
um I I wish someone had
almost prepared me for how hard it was
it was sort of like other moms started
talking about it right around the you
know when they were all going but man it
was um
it was
very very hard it was very hard and um
you know that's my like she's like my
ray of sunshine and um it's been it's
been hard without her but I'm also so
proud of her she's so happy and it was
it's amazing to see this independent
strong young woman stand on her own two
feet and emerge and it's being part of a
student body it's I'm very very proud of
her but at the end of the day though we
still need our mama thank you
and I'm sure like do you get the little
text like Mom wait how do I my laundry
this can I put this in the dryer or how
do I cook this on what do you still get
all of that because that was me I get it
every day there's some little question
or you know it's and it's great it's
it's it's nice I mean the relationship
you can see how it's like the first
taste of what the adult relationship
will be with her now do either of your
kids want to pursue the Arts at all
whether it be music or acting Apple
she's very open to life right now and
she doesn't think about it in those
terms
Moses is very into music and
um so we'll see I don't know if he wants
to do it for a career
um but I think you know both of my kids
are certainly
creatives but they're also academics as
well so I don't know we'll see what
they're gonna do
[Music]